now the government is to invest nearly
30 million pounds in new labs and
testing at its port and down facility
to assess the effectiveness of
coronavirus vaccines against
new variants now let's hope this is
going to speed up the deployment of
vaccines which are tailored to tackle
variants of concern well let's talk to
the vaccines minister
nadim zahawi good to see you this
morning so this additional 30 million
looks like
almost 50 million pounds invested in
portland down
since september i mean in real terms
what difference is this going to make
so back in september the facility could
test about 700
blood samples every week
we made a 20 million just shy of 20
million investment
in there to raise that to 1500 plant
samples every week
and we're going further what we're
announcing today is a further
just shy of 30 million so bringing the
investment total to 50 million
to take that scale from 700
tests a week to 3 000 plus sample tests
a week all part of our future proofing
as the secretary of state for health uh
said in terms
of always being ahead of the virus
as it mutates to survive we need to make
sure that we have
vaccine variants that are ready for any
virus variant
that may escape the good news is the
current vaccination
program and the vaccines we're deploying
are working effectively against the
dominant
virus in the united kingdom what about
the time scale
in all of this i mean what difference is
it going to make in the
next few months when obviously we've got
these real concerns about variants
coming through
how quickly can these new labs new
facilities be online
so this new investment will deliver in
january of next year but we also have
a capability to genome sequence in the
united kingdom that is
one of the largest what we account for
just shy of 50
of all the sequencing being done of the
different virus mutations
in the world and of course a few weeks
ago we made that big offer
to other countries where they don't have
that capability genome sequence to do
that for them to hold a library so
the deal we announced with cure vac with
the messenger rna vaccine in the uk is
to
effectively give them a library of all
the virus
variants mutations so that they can be
ready with the messenger rna
vaccine for us as well of course the
investment we're making
in val neva in scotland which is a whole
inactivated
virus that makes up the vaccine so
a lot of work both with the current
manufacturers we're talking to
astrazeneca and oxford team about a
vaccine variant
we've bought 60 million of pfizer we're
talking to moderna
about their vaccine variant as well as
of course this investment
today to make sure that we've got the
laboratory analysis to do all this work
in the uk so we stay we remain now ahead
of the virus all the time what about i
mean
this must have been in play these plans
must have been in play for some time why
announce
them today the day before local and
mayoral elections
uh the honest truth is until you make
the investment
and they're ready we we announce when we
sign when we
actually when you know the system is
ready to accept
that investment when the plans are
signed off so
um you know ministers and i i hear the
cynicism in your in your voice
ministers have have very little to do
with with the timing it's all about
making sure we back our scientists we
back
uh public health england we back the
team at port and down who've done
an amazing job uh through this pandemic
but the the the principle of this is to
future proof
the uh vaccination program uh for
the autumn and then for years to come
because as we move
hopefully from pandemic to endemic this
will be similar to the sort of annual
flu vaccination program where
the scientists will decide as they do at
who
which variants are the most concerned
and then we we effectively formulate a
vaccine to deal with those
where does this leave us in terms of
vaccine diplomacy
because i mean obviously what you're
saying is is that the new work at
portland
is going to have a global impact which
is welcome but in terms of immediate
things we can do the us
is now sending 10 of the united states
produced vaccines
by other countries by start of start of
july
do we need to start making similar
commitments now
so let me just you know place on record
for your viewers
the oxford astrozenica vaccine
way back from last year and
the oxford team and astrazeneca
licensing that vaccine
to the serum institute for example in
india at
zero profit has meant that they will
produce with uk funding we've put
over half a billion pounds into kovacs a
billion doses
for low income and middle-income
countries a billion doses so
put that into perspective of all the
other donations that are taking place
that's a big big
number already over 40 million doses
have arrived in
ghana and the ivory coast and the
philippines
the bulk of that is the astrazeneca
oxford vaccine
it's great news that albert baller and
pfizer are doing the same thing
putting more through kovacs but we will
go further as well
uh in terms of the prime minister and
the foreign secretary
have already talked about our commitment
to kovacs in terms of
excess vaccines and of course the help
to india where we've already delivered
first tranche was 600 i think 400
ventilators 290 oxygen
concentrators three big or three mini
oxygen factories and a further 1 000
ventilators
so we're doing both the work on vaccines
and on helping india of course on
vital medical equipment that they need
to deal with the current
spike that they're sadly facing in in
terms of vaccines that we need in this
country i mean there's
obviously it now looks like this booster
is going to go i mean certainly for the
over 50s in the autumn and
possibly wider reaching than that we've
ordered the 60 million doses of pfizer
to cover the booster
why fisa and not astrazeneca for the
booster so this is
really important what we will do in the
vaccines task force is make sure that
the
scientist chris whittie the chief
medical officer with his
fellow chief medical officers from wales
scotland and northern ireland will make
that decision at the moment
they're still looking at the data to see
whether
the durability of the current
vaccination program
how far it lasts but we want them to be
able
if they need to from september onwards
to boost
those that are most vulnerable so if you
remember we've vaccinated the
residence of care homes the over 80s
over 75s over 70s
and those that are clinically extremely
vulnerable now
pfizer is one option we are going to
give them an astrazeneca oxford option
we're working with the team
on an on a vaccine variant novovax is
another option which has been
manufactured in t-side
filled and finished at barnard castle
that works very well against both
the south african variant and the kent
variant
and of course valeneva in scotland um
and
curvac that i talked about but they
haven't made that decision yet it's very
important for your viewers to know
that the clinicians haven't yet made the
decision when they will
need to boost whether to give more more
immunity to the most vulnerable uh to
increase the durability of the
protection
or to deal with a variant when they
decide i want to give them
as much optionality as many vaccines
that work then they will make those
choices there is a clinical trial that
jonathan van tam is conducting
boost which looks at which vaccine
delivers the best boost so it's not just
pfizer it could be astrazeneca
it could be novovax it could be the
valeneva vaccine
so all that work is happening right now
so that when the clinicians say go
the nhs is putting plans in place now
to deploy from september onwards if
needed it may not be september it could
be maybe later in the year or
early next year but the nhs has plans
they need to dovetail of course with the
flu vaccination program because we've
been to flu season
by then all that work we're doing right
now
to make sure we future-proof the the
sort of the short-term boost and then
the longer term annual covert
flu vaccination program um yesterday i
was talking
uh about the the g7 summit the in-person
meeting and we called it a covid secure
meeting and i said on there well
of course it's a covent secure meeting
there's been a there's been a covert
scare
hasn't there at the g7 do we know how
many members of the delegation
are self-isolating i don't um
i'm afraid but um obviously you know
public health england
and the team that are organizing the g7
take
this very seriously as you saw the
pictures you were you were broadcasting
the pictures yesterday
of the different delegations uh being
tested so
we continue to have one of the most
robust
um set of protocols around testing
uh and so we we will make sure that
happens but i don't
know the numbers so uh so so there has
been a schedule you know if anyone was
testing
positivity this is news to me i mean
you're telling me this
as as we speak so i i can't really
comment on this
right right well we again waited for
absolute confirmation but
one of the special advisers was
indicating this this was the case so
but we will be fully you know fully
across that and do whatever take
whatever measures are necessary
absolutely um can we move on to
brexit um because of the the situation
we've got with
with jersey now and there's a row over
fishing rights
uh with around the jersey territorial
waters and
france now saying they they are willing
to cut off power supply to jersey
if this row isn't sorted out what do you
make of that
well i think the on the positive side
it was really good to see the european
parliament ratify what i think is an
historic
agreement between the united kingdom and
our eu
neighbours uh that was really important
that happened at the end of
uh last month that was a big
um moving on moving forward i should say
the important thing i think is that both
sides uh
david frost and of course his
counterparts
now continue to work together to make
sure that operationally
on the ground we iron out
any issues any problems so that this
historic deal between the united kingdom
and the eu one of the most important
deals
we have struck we've put in place works
for people for communities for the
uh fishing communities for other people
and i think
uh my my very strong
um feeling on this
is that we need to work constructively
and actually people are working
constructively on both sides but when
when
when france is turning around saying
they're prepared to turn the lights off
on jersey i mean that's not very
diplomatic is it i mean do we need to
look at what we're doing and
they're accusing us of using red tape to
limit their their fishing ability i mean
we
we've got to look at this urgently well
as i say this is uh
an issue for the commission to work with
our team with david frost
and all the indications from
uh minister frost and his team is that
the commission is taking
seriously some of these
operational challenges that we need to
fix together
that's the best way to do this in the
same way we're doing now on
uh our vaccine program it's great to see
spain and france and germany really
begin to accelerate the vaccination
program
we send millions of the the the
nanoparticles that carry the pfizer
messenger rna
that delivers those jabs from a great
business called croda in the uk
to the eu and they send us back uh both
the the fisa vaccine and of course uh
other
uh vaccines and you know we it's much
better to work
together on this stuff than it is to to
uh
in some you know to allow some of these
operational challenges to become
confrontational in terms of europe a lot
of us are wanting to go there
in in the summer and some of this is
going to be dependent
on the getting the nhs app to be
to have vaccination certificates or
test certification on board that's going
to happen
quickly we need it for the 17th of may
we understand that there's a
struggling to get that done in time is
is that right how soon can we expect
that to be working
well the team under nhs x that's leading
on the
matagould is i think doing a really
important job they're already piloting
we had a pilot and kettering hospital on
this
the app is one part of the certification
process so very important that people
have the capability
uh to be able to demonstrate they've had
a test as we require other
uh essential travel from non-red list
countries of course because what 40
countries on the red list
to have a a pre-departure test we have
the same thing so we have got to be able
to show it
but also physically some people don't
have a smartphone
and we are making that nhs will make
that provision also available and i'm
confident
they'll be able to deliver on that the
important thing is that the transport
secretary grant shap is actually
leading his g7 colleagues to
essentially agree the protocols for
travel around the world
because what you want is a global
protocol that works for our citizens
that we can shape which is why the work
that he's doing and he'll say a bit
more on this uh at the end of this week
in terms obviously the
traffic light system of countries that
are green amber or red
okay minister good to see you as always
thank you great to see